[Music]
welcome to the apogee up close webcast
we do these twice a month and the topics
change based on demand
hi i'm keith daneken i'm an apogee
customer engineer so for today's agenda
we're gonna do a brief overview of api
management
and apogee edge then i'm going to do a
demo in apigee edge and show you a few
things in there
and then i'll take some questions let's
get started
so let's talk about api management let's
consider a scenario
let's suppose you've got some services
over there on the right-hand side
so anything you happen to have around
rest services soap services
microservices maybe it's your service
bus anything over there
we've got some folks over here on the
left partners employees customers
and they have applications and those
applications need to get data
from these services there's a need to
control what those applications can do
and how they can access that data and
how frequently and things like that
that's where api management comes in
that's where apigee edge fits in here
so we put apogee edge in here to control
how those applications can access that
right hand side
now we also have to think about
application developers the people who
write all those applications
how will they gain access to these
systems what do we need to do in order
to get them credentials
so that apogee will let them into those
back-end services how will they read
documentation how will they learn how
your apis work
and how will they sign up for access
along the way as traffic starts to flow
through here
we'd also like to be able to create some
reports that tells us about which
applications are accessing this
what they're doing how frequently
they're calling what's the level of
traffic how does it compare to past
trends and things like that
so a few more things we might want to do
we could use apogee in here to build a
facade over the back
services we can present one set of
interfaces to those
external applications compared to what's
inside
we can control access so different
applications might have access to
different services
and they might get different things when
they call them we can rate limit to
protect those back end services
if one of those applications is calling
too quickly we can shut it down
we could also impose some quotas maybe
we want to give
developers limited access to some of
these things and we may want to charge
money for other things
we can add caching in there to improve
performance so if we already have the
answer in apogee edge we don't need to
call the back end
we could reformat that request as it
comes in and make it appropriate for
those backend services
the response that comes from the backend
services we could change that around too
before we send it back to the
applications
we could manage a whole collection of
those app developers out there and
manage their credentials
and along the way we could collect usage
analytics and that would give us some
insights into how our api program is
going
so these are all things you might want
to do with an api management platform
and this is a good overview of what api
management is
there's a new way to think about the
problem of services
traditionally we would have thought of
this as an exposure problem so we've got
some
data we need to expose it through a
service but there's a better way to
think about this
a pattern that we've seen our most
successful customers adopt and that's to
think about it from the outside in
meaning that rather than just thinking
about exposing a service what we're
actually thinking about
is the end user who will use the
application what's that user's
experience
what is it like to use the application
that they're using and how do we empower
the developer who writes that
application
that comes from having great apis and
building a set of apis that are very
nice to use for
that developer and that's what the api
team does so if we think about this
from the outside inward we'll have much
better success
there are a lot of people who use apogee
edge what's interesting for me when i
look at this slide is i look at all the
different businesses that these people
are in
what they all have in common is they're
seeing success from having an api
program either internal or external
so let's look at apigee edge apogee edge
is an api management platform and we can
think of it in three major parts
we can think of it as a set of api
services that's the part that routes
traffic that's the thing that we put
between the applications and the
services
and we can think of some needs in there
along the lines of security
transforming messages acting as an
enterprise gateway
orchestrating those back-end services
and preventing people from
abusing those services in terms of
developer engagement we need to have a
developer portal and that's a good place
to put documentation and for developers
to come who want to consume these apis
and read about how to use them
there's a need to have api products so a
way to take all these services and
bundle them together into different
packages that provide different access
and there may be a need to monetize
services where we're going to charge
money for access
finally we need a way to measure
everything and that's where api
analytics comes in
we can measure developer engagement we
can measure business metrics we can look
at operational metrics
api program metrics and we can monitor
the platform to see how it's working
so all this together makes an api
management platform
so what's the difference between an api
gateway and an api management platform
well an api gateway is a small subset of
an api management platform
as you can see from this slide an api
management platform does a lot more than
you would do with a simple gateway
so gateway would do basic things like
collect security tokens
but there's a lot more to solving the
api problem than there is with a simple
gateway
so let's talk about some advantages that
apogee has over other solutions in the
marketplace
in gartner's recent magic quadrant
survey they found apogee to be a leader
and they ranked apogee highest in terms
of the ability to execute and the
completeness of their vision
you can find more about this on the
apigee website there are a few different
options in terms of how you deploy
apogee
apigee is offered as a software as a
service managed in google cloud
you can run it on premises in a data
center you can run it in the cloud of
your choice
or you can run hybrid where most of it
runs in the cloud and some of it's going
to run near your computing resources
these are all different options for
running apogee edge
apigee edge offers global scale and
availability it's hosted in 13 data
centers around the world
and historically we had 99.999
availability
the developer portal within apogee edge
can be easily customized to meet your
needs
if this is an internal portal you might
keep it kind of simple but if it's
external facing you might want to brand
it to
match your branding of your website
apigee gives you a choice between
configuration or coding
there's a number of out-of-the-box
policies that do basic things that's
what we're seeing on the left here
you can drop in these policies to
request an access token
or add response caching if you want to
do code driven development you can build
your own
policies and you can drop those in and
mix them with the out of the box
policies
and that can be done with javascript
java or python and you can also host
node.js in here
apogee edge has a wonderful analytic
system you can use it to provide
real-time visibility into the activity
in the system
you can also use to measure and grow
your digital ecosystem
so you can look at operational metrics
but you can also look at business
metrics
apigee offers monetization so if you
decide you want to charge for access to
your apis there's a monetization add-on
that you can get for apigee to do this
you can do revenue sharing models fee
based models or freemium models maybe
the first 100 calls are free
and if you want something more than that
then you have to pay
apogee sense is another option you can
add apogee sense to do bot detection
and detect malicious traffic so you
won't necessarily see this in the demo
today
but apogee has a collection of
management apis
and these let you control every aspect
of the platform programmatically through
a rest-based api
this can be used to automate operation
of apigee maybe you want to
automate the creation of users or
credentials for people
or maybe you want to use this to push
things into production automatically
after running a series of tests
there's apis to do all of that there's a
wonderful community
and a bunch of resources to help you
with apogee so there's
community.apigee.com with over 10 000
users
we've got a series of four minute videos
one for each feature in the product you
can go in and learn about the spike
arrest in four minutes for example
there's a number of webcasts that are
out there you find those on youtube
there's customer stories where we
interview customers and they talk about
what they do with apogee and we publish
a bunch of ebooks
all of these are great resources to help
you become productive with the platform
so let's look at a demo what we're going
to look at in the demo today
is a simple set of apis that sit on top
of a set of weather data
the weather data is in bigquery and
there's weather stations from all around
the world
you can look those up by latitude and
longitude and for any given weather
station you can pull down historical
weather
so this is what i've got on the back all
the way on the right hand side here
we've got weather data stored in
bigquery
in order to get at that data i've got to
log in using a service account in google
cloud and in order to get credentials
for that i have to talk to cloud
identity and access management
so i'm going to send some credentials
over there and it's going to return to
me in oauth token
and with every request i make into the
weather database i've got to send that
credential as a header on the left hand
side of this
i didn't want to have that security so
what i'm doing instead is i'm using api
keys
so i have a single page web application
i've got a few mobile applications
each of those has their own api key so
i'm splitting the security
into two different parts here the back
end security and the front-end security
there's some other things going to do on
here also i want to build a facade on
that back end and hide away the details
of where this data is
and i want to control access to some
features only limited things you can do
in here
i want a rate limit to protect that back
end i don't want people calling this too
much
and i'm going to impose some quotas so
depending on which api product you're
using
you'll have different quotas i'm going
to add caching to help performance
i'm going to reformat the request as it
comes in and the response when it comes
back in order to make this more friendly
to my developers that want to use this
api
in the demo we're going to consider
three perspectives the first one is the
application developer api consumer
and that person might be saying all i
want to do is build an application
make it easy for me to consume your
services we'll look at the api developer
they might be saying i need to share a
service with other people but with some
limits
and we'll look at the api team and they
might be saying i want to think about
apis as software products
their customers life cycles versions i
want to measure my program at tunit
as a developer i might start here on the
developer portal
from here i can get what i need in order
to be productive with these apis
and to start using them in my
application i see there's a number of
api
products and something that says get
started on here let's look at the
available api products
so i can see that there are a few apis
available let's look at this one
so here's some documentation on how
these apis work i'm looking at the
weather stations api
there's a url in there and it looks like
i can put in a
location and i need an api key and then
it'll give me a list of weather stations
so i'd like to actually try this out
to do that i'm going to go up and
register a new application
we'll call the webcast demo app
and we're going to go with this package
now that's registered my application and
i've got an api key
let's go back to the docs and give this
a try
i'll put my api key in there
and we'll put it in location
i'm near boulder colorado let's check
the weather for there
and i see a list of weather stations
that are near boulder colorado
so what i like about this is i can try
out the api right here and i get an idea
of what i need to send in and what need
and what will come back in the response
and that makes me pretty productive i
could start coding at this point
so i visited the developer portal i read
the documentation on how to use the api
and then i registered an application and
that returned a key for me i took the
key over to the documentation i was able
to test it out in there
and i have a pretty good feel for what
it's like to call the api now
so i can make a call in here and get
data back the next thing to do is let's
write an application
so i've got a simple application that
i've written here and what this allows
you to do
is you can search for weather stations
by typing in an address or landmark up
here
and then you get back a list of weather
stations and you can check for high and
low
temperature data at that particular
weather station
so i'm near boulder colorado let's look
and see what weather stations are around
here
so i type in this location and it's
going to find me weather stations that
are near that location
they get populated down here so it looks
like it's found a few
i'm going to go with this one specify a
year in here
and then i can run a query and that's
going to pull down the historical
temperature data so this is for the
boulder location 2015 and we can see the
high temperature data
and the low temperature data in here so
not bad
this was pretty easy to write took me
about an hour most of it was spent
trying to format these graphs and to
make them look nice i added this little
status button down here so we could see
what was returned
i got a nice 200 there if i run this a
few times let's see what happens
so i called too quickly and i got shut
down with some rate limiting
so that's our simple application let's
switch roles to the api developer and
see what we had to build
in order to make this possible so as the
api developer there's a few things i'm
going to do
what i did when i was building this
particular demo was first thing i did
was fire up postman
and i called my back end service a few
times and played around with the red
documentation and figured out what it
could do and
that influenced what i wanted to do in
terms of building an api proxy for it
so once i decided on that and i was
happy with how the backend service
works i came into here and then i built
a specification to describe my api
let's look at that so here's my weather
history
api spec
i've described how it works and the
three different services you might call
underneath there one two
look up weather stations one to look up
temperature data and one to look up wind
data
i've specified all that in here
i can see what the documentation is
going to look like i've specified what
the results look like so this should
give my developers a good idea
of exactly how this works
so the next step is to build an api
proxy you might come to this screen
under api proxies and hit this plus
proxy button up here
so we have a few choices in here reverse
proxy the first one is the most common
and this is where i started you can use
an open api spec if you have one
or you can just start with a url and
make a straight through connection and
start to build up your proxy from there
there's a few other options in here if i
was working with a soap service i might
choose this second one
and that gives me an option to build
either a straight through connection to
an existing soap service
or to possibly build something that does
soap to rest and rest to soap conversion
and that would i'd supply the wisdol and
it would build something for me
i might use no target if i wanted to
mock this up
so what it does in that case is apogee
is going to return the response and it's
not going to talk to a back-end system
so i might mock up the response inside
of this proxy
and i could use that to provide sample
data to my developers
hosted target and node.js allows me to
host node.js in here
and i might do that if i were going to
orchestrate several back-end systems and
i want
the back end that's called by apigee to
be this node.js code that then calls
other services
and if someone sent me a proxy bundle
they they've developed i would use this
last option to import it
so i entered my spec and that created my
api proxy for me and put me into the
editor so let's look at that
so let's look at the existing api
this is where i'll develop the api that
outside consumers are going to use
key things to notice here are target
endpoints down there
and this is the backend url that's going
to be called
so instead of calling that directly my
consumers will now call one of these
urls up here
that talks to apogee and then apogee
sends the request to the back end
we also have you'll notice there's two
different urls here i have a few
different environments i can deploy into
in my demo environment here i have a
test and a production environment that's
available to me
and i have version seven in production
and version eight in test
so they'll call those urls to talk to
the back end system it'll be managed by
apigee
and traffic will flow back and forth so
let's dig in a little further and see
what's over in develop
so we're over here on the develop tab
and what we'll notice in here is there's
a few different sections to this screen
let me go through those
and then i'll go into some details so up
here we have a graphical depiction of
the request and the response flow so the
request comes in
goes the back end target and then the
response comes back
and along the way we can have some of
these policies in place they're going to
help manage this request and response
flow
those policies are configured down here
at the bottom so i'll click on one of
these and you can see how it's
configured at the bottom
policies that i've used in here are
listed over here i can reuse these i can
drag and drop them over here
things the requests go on the top things
for the response go on the bottom
we have two sections down here proxy
endpoints and target endpoints
proxy endpoints control what happens
between the client and apogee and target
endpoints control what happens between
apogee and the back end
so for proxy endpoints there's a few
different flows in here the pre-flow
is executed unconditionally at the
beginning so people
might put different things on the end of
the url they might call this in
different ways with a post or a put or
get or something like that
we may want to have the system behave
differently depending on how they're
calling it
so preflow is always called first
unconditionally i tend to put things in
here like checking for security tokens
and rate limiting and things like that
the next few that i've got in here are
conditional so i can click in here and i
can add a new one
and i can choose a path and a verb in
some sort of condition
so those are called conditionally so if
somebody calls my
url with slash stations at the end that
gets called if they call that with a
http get
same thing for temperature and wind and
then post flow is called unconditionally
at the end after the others execute so
first pre-flow
anything conditional and then post flow
the same conditions hold true for the
target back ends
in my case i've only got one back end
and i don't have any specific logic in
there but let's imagine we had a bunch
of different back end systems
and we might be doing some dynamic
routing among them we can have different
conditions in here for those different
endpoints down here i've got some
resources so these are
javascript files in this case so things
like code and files
that are associated with this api proxy
go down here and i've got javascript
policies that reference some source code
and that's the source code right there
so let's look a little bit in more
detail in here
so we have a few policies in place up
here where did they come from
i came over to here and i hit the plus
step button
and inside of here i'm greeted with a
menu of
possible policies that i could put in
there there's a few things around
traffic management there's some around
security
some around mediation and then some
extensions
so let's look at each section here
traffic management is going to do
basic traffic management things so quota
quota would limit how many times you can
call something in a certain period of
time so maybe i want to
limit this to 100 calls per day spike
arrest
is going to limit how it's called but
based on frequency so
think of this like a circuit breaker you
don't want somebody to call this too
fast
i might set this to 100 transactions per
second and if they call at a rate
greater than that
it'll return an error we have several
policies for caching so
basic response cache and the ability to
manipulate these different caches
programmatically
you can have named caches multiple
caches they can have different times to
live
and you can use them at different points
in your flows
for security we've got a number of
options in here basic auth is going to
request a username and password from
somebody who's calling the system
or it can be used to construct a header
to send to a back-end system that
expects
that the next three policies are there
to make sure that
bad things don't get through in the
request
we have a full implementation of oauth
2. we can check oauth tokens we can
generate oauth tokens
for backwards compatibility there's some
oauth 1.0 in here
we have the ability to verify api keys
access control would let us limit calls
to a certain range of ip addresses we
can blacklist or whitelist certain ip
ranges
if we need to generate or validate saml
we have saml assertions in here and we
can work with jwts
under mediation we have policies for
json to xml xml to json
we can raise custom error messages check
monetization limits we can do xslt and
soap message validation
assign message and extract variables i
use a lot a sign message lets me change
the request or the response in some way
so let's say i want to insert a header
or i want to take something out of a url
and put it into the body i'd use that
with a signed message
extract variables lets me grab something
out of that request a response
and use it as a variable inside of
apigee access entity lets us load up
metadata
and key value operations lets us work
with the key value map it's a very nice
key value map inside of apigee edge
that lets you store anything that you
need at different scopes so for example
in here i store an api key that i need
to talk to google maps
and i'll use the key value map pull that
out of there stick it into a request and
make my call
so those are the basic policies that do
things that are very common
we also have some extensions in here so
if you
want to do things in programming
languages we have java python and
javascript are supported
with those languages you have complete
control over the request and response
there's variables in there to be able to
grab things like headers and stuff like
that or the body content you can change
it around
and replace it we'll see an example that
in my demo
service callout lets me do an http
callout before i call the back end so
for example in my demo i use that
when i type in the location of a city it
makes a call out to google maps and
returns a latitude and longitude
and then send that to the back end
flowcall
lets me execute a shared flow so let's
say i've got a flow that i want to use
in
many of these different api proxies i
can build a shared flow for that and i
access it with a flow callout that lets
me reuse code
the statistics collector will allow me
to store
a variable in the analytics system so if
i want to build a custom report i can
grab data from this custom
variable and i can i can show a custom
report with that
i can log something to a logging system
maybe
if this rate limit is hit too often i
might log that and then there's a number
of extensions that we can use that make
our
our back end systems easier to work with
so that's the basic policies that are
available to you
let's look at a few of the policies i
used
first thing i'm going to do in here is
check for an api key and i'm looking for
an api
key as a query parameter if i don't get
one this is going to return an
unauthorized error
i'm rate limiting i'm limiting somebody
to 10 calls per minute in here if they
call faster than that will return an
error
i'm checking a quota the quote is based
off of an api
product so we can have different quotas
for different people calling this
we've got a response cache in there so
if i already have the answer to this if
somebody sends me the same request
in a row i'm going to grab that from
memory and there's my shared flow that's
going to log me into google cloud
so that's a few things i do with every
call that comes in
this flow is where i look up weather
stations so someone specified a
particular location
an airport or a city or something like
that and i want to find weather stations
that are near there
so the first thing i do is i'm going to
make a call to google maps but i need
something before that i need my api key
that gets me into google maps
so i'm looking that up from the key
value map from there i'm going to
construct a request and i'm going to
send that
address or location into google maps i'm
going to ask it what's the latitude and
longitude
and i need to pass along an api key to
identify me
then i'll call this url down here that's
going to respond back with a description
of the location
and that has a lot of information in
there there's two pieces of information
that i'm really interested in really the
only thing i want out of there
is latitude and longitude of that
particular location
so that is buried in a certain section
that's under geometry dot location
and then underneath there are latitude
and longitude so i've got a json path in
here
to show where those variables are and
then i'm going to store the values of
those in lat
and lawn next i'll construct a bounding
box
around that particular location so what
this javascript code is going to do
is create four variables down there a
minimum longitude
a minimum latitude a maximum longitude
and a maximum latitude
and those are stored as variables that i
can then access later in the flow so
that's what all this code does
and then next i'll construct the query
in here so i've taken
all this information that i've gathered
and i've used that to build this query
up
now when somebody called this they just
sent a location and it didn't have
anything to do with databases or any
kind of query language or anything like
that
so i'm taking the request that was sent
in that contained that address
i've gone and looked it up and
calculated some latitudes and longitudes
and i've built this query and that's
what i'm going to send to the back end
so that goes to the backend i've
completely replaced the
payload in here with this that goes to
the back end
and then we'll get a response and then
down here i reformat the response so
that it looks a little bit nicer
so i'm really just taking the uh the
code that comes back and reformatting it
to make a little bit nicer and i'm
sorting it
by distance
so that's the basic flow if we go into a
little more detail here we want to look
up
once somebody has a weather station and
they make a request
what does that look like so they make a
call in with slash temperature
and they're going to supply a few things
on the url i need to grab that data off
of the url
and then i'm going to go and find the
data for that particular weather station
in that year
so this first policy here is going to
grab the variables that i need from the
url
so they're calling stations they've
supplied a weather station id right
there
and it's followed by years and then a
particular year is supplied there
so i want to grab these two pieces of
information and store them as variables
and then my next step in here is to
build a query for this and i'm going to
send that
into bigquery and it's going to return a
big set of data for me
and again i've replaced the request with
a different one
this is a statistics collector and it's
going to save the weather station id in
case i want to run a report on traffic
by weather station id to see which
weather stations are popular
so that's how i built my api proxy this
is a bit more complicated than what most
people would build
most people are going to take a back-end
service and they might just be
collecting a security token
and then sending the response back you
know without any modification
and that's a great place to start i
wanted to show this to you because it
shows all the different things you could
do with apigee if you wanted to
much simpler things can be done and
that's a lot easier
so when i was building this it didn't
quite work at first
i had the request in the wrong format
and when i sent it to bigquery on the
back end
it returned an error and what i realized
was something in my request was a little
bit off
so i ran over to the trace tool over
here and this helped me debug
let's start a trace session and see how
this works i'm going to click on the
button there to start up my trace
session and then i'm going to go out to
my client application
and send in a few requests let's go back
to something that's not cached and see
how that looks
so we'll see requests start to come
streaming through in here
i'll run a few of these so we have a
very a variety of results
so here we see a call entering and this
one is for temperature data
for 2014 for this particular weather
station and there's our api key on the
end of that
so we see this coming in we see
the request content
let's look at the steps and see how it
got that way so there's the api key
check
what we're seeing in here is a whole
bunch of information
about this so when the api key is
evaluated by
apogee it loads up a ton of metadata and
you can use these all these become
variables in here and they can be used
throughout your flow
for different things maybe you want to
dynamically route somebody to a
different server
based on some sort of metadata that's
associated with this key
we'll see the spike arrest and the quota
policy being checked
it's looking to see if we have the cache
there's a false there to say it wasn't
found in cache
and then this is my shared flow that
authorizes me with
with bigquery
we'll see the variables being extracted
and then the final request is sent in
and we can see that this looks very
different so
we saw it came in as a get here and then
it went out like this
so we're seeing it turned into a post so
there's the post and that's what's going
out to the back end
we see the response coming back so we
can see the format of the data that's
returned from bigquery
so we can see that i changed that around
a little bit made a little bit cleaner
and easier for the developer to
understand
so that's a basic flow in here this
second one we'll notice is a bit shorter
and that's because we're hitting cash so
the response is being returned
straight from cash and it's a lot faster
too
here's our rate limiting so in this case
uh
apogee edge detected that this is being
called too quickly
and it shut it down so i've got this
spike arrest right here
that was tripped and then we'll see that
a custom error message
is sent back and it says callraid
exceeded this application is limited to
10 requests per minute
then we give our developer a pretty good
hint about what's going on so you have a
good idea of
exactly what went wrong now when i was
building this api proxy
i found out that i had something a
little bit wrong in that query so i had
gotten a quote in the wrong place
and so bigquery was rejecting it and i
saw that in the trace tool when i looked
at the payload
i could see that the mistake was in
there i went back and fixed it so this
is really helpful for me
it helped me find that mistake in a big
hurry and i was able to fix it
so that's how we would debug and trace
something
the next thing to think about is
publishing how do we take this
and publish it out so that somebody can
use it
so i want to talk about the concept of
api products and this will become
important when we start to think about
how to publish our apis out for
consumption
so we use api products in apigee edge to
share your apis with consumers
let's think about this for a minute
we're not just thinking about
services anymore these are now becoming
products and so there's a whole life
cycle of these apis that people want to
consume
we've got to think about how we might
manage that so we're going to take a
formal approach to this and we're going
to think of these as products and a
product might contain more than one
service
so what that looks like inside of apigee
edge is we've got those api proxies over
there on the left and that's what you
saw me walking through here i've got
this particular weather api
and i can have a number of products that
give access to that
so i have silver access gold access and
platinum access as an example here and
they give you different entitlements and
those are
different metadata that's associated
with those products
so silver gives us a hundred calls per
day with five calls per minute and some
limited access we only do some things
so for example i might only be able to
look up weather stations but i can't get
temperature
or wind data and gold access might
entitle me to more calls
and it would give me full access to all
those different things that are in the
apis so i have a series of these
products but people don't have access
yet
if i want to grant somebody access to
call this api i'm going to register an
application
so let's say we're building the android
application
for looking at weather history i'd
register my application
and some metadata associated with that
and that would generate some keys for me
that i could use to call into the system
so
you register an application and that
gives you access to one or more products
and those products have entitlements to
use certain apis
so we don't just have a service and
everybody calls it we don't know who's
who
we're going to have a system in here for
managing products and we give people
access to these products
they have api keys or they're going to
be sending oauth tokens or jwts
and that lets us track exactly who's
calling things
so where do we get these keys we create
an api product inside of apigee we
decide which proxies are going to go in
there and which resources of those
from there we register a developer
application and a developer can have
access
to more than one api product and that
generates two keys a consumer key and a
consumer secret key and use the consumer
key
as your api key or you're going to use
both keys if you're going to generate an
oauth token
so that's a quick overview of api
products let's go back and see how we do
that inside of apigee
so let's click over here on the box and
we'll see that in this section we've got
something called api products
and i'll show you an api product that i
built for my weather demo
so we have the weather history try it
out down here let me put this in edit
mode so you can see what it was like
when i created it
so i called this weather history try it
and it provides 100 calls per day for
development usage
and the access is public meaning it'll
show up on my portal
i've got a hundred requests for every
one day and that's the quota
this describes what's available in my
api so
anybody who calls that url i could
specify in here
something a little more detailed like
slash temperature or
or slash stations if i wanted to and
then we can see down here all the
different
developer apps that make use of this
product
so let's look at the
let's look at the webcast demo app
so here's our application we can see
that its usage was approved
and we have a key and a secret that we
can use for calling this
if i wanted to add custom attributes i
can do so down here
i might have partner id on there or
something like that that's meaningful to
my business and whenever this api
key comes through here that variable
will be loaded up and i can use it for
logging or
for traffic redirection or figuring out
how to
limit them or whatever i want to do with
it so this is one way to create an
application
and register it you can do it by hand in
here and i can register this for a
particular developer
i send these credentials to the
developer and they're good to go
but another way to do that probably a
more common way to do that
is that the developer would do this and
they're going to do that using a
developer portal
so our third perspective is the api team
let's look at how they would use apogee
to manage their api program
the api team has an interest in knowing
how things are running
so they may come into the analyze tab
over here and look at some of these
reports
the first one we'll look at here is
proxy performance and this is just going
to show us
the very basics so how much traffic did
we get what was the average response
time
what's the traffic by proxy and what's
the average response time by proxy
so quick high level summary of what's
going on i could change the dimension up
here from hour to day to week or some
custom time period
another report that might be interesting
is developer engagement so
who is writing applications so we've got
10 total developers that are registered
seven have registered applications and
four are highly active
are four are active and two are highly
active
this gives us an idea of who's using the
system
and who's going to be using it in the
future
the devices report is going to show us
what kind of devices people are using so
who's on which type of browser are they
on a mobile device
are they on a desktop are they running
chrome are they running firefox
maybe there's a few folks that are still
on internet explorer we can see all that
on this report
and that might help us guide where we
spend our development in terms of
applications
the map shows us where our traffic is
coming from so we've got traffic
coming from the united states here and
some calls from canada
we click through we'll see that
colorado's highlighting that's where i
am and that's where i'm sending my
request from
target performance is going to show us
how the backend system is keeping up
so this gives us an idea over time of
what the response time is for the back
end system
and traffic composition will show us our
top 10 proxies top 10 apps
top 10 products and give us an idea of
what's most popular at this time
and there's a bunch more reports in here
that you can look at that do different
things
you can also build custom reports and
you can grab anything you want out of
the request of the response
and build a full-featured custom report
that gives you exactly what you want to
see
finally our api team might also be
interested in monitoring so they might
come over to the monitoring dashboard
and this is where we could set alerts if
we want to configure some alerts and
some notifications
when things happen in the system we can
do that in here
this is a whole other topic that's worth
digging into but we're going to
cut short on this for interest of time
so we looked at the demo from three
different perspectives we looked at how
the application developer or api
consumer
was able to easily go out to a portal
learn everything that was required get
credentials
and start building an application and
sending in traffic very quickly
the amount of friction required to build
that first app is very low
we saw how the api developer took an
existing service and started to manage
it with apogee
and put some products in place so it was
easy for these developers to consume it
and finally we saw how the api team
would look at some analytics dashboards
and monitor how their program is going
and use the monitoring features to make
sure everything's running smoothly
so let's take some questions so first
question in here is
how do you do versioning in apogee
so um good question i get this a lot so
there's
quite a bit of religion around
versioning what i typically recommend to
people
is that you've got a url and that url
is going to have the version number in
it so put a v1 or a v2 in your url as
as far to the left as you possibly can
so
what you do in apogee is you can take
your proxy
and you can save it as a new revision
and then inside of there you just change
the url that it's listening on so you
might have v1
weather demo for example or v2 weather
demo and then you're free to change that
around as needed
so that's versioning there's also the
concept of
revisioning so apogee has a built-in
revisioning system
you might have noticed in the demo that
i was on like revision 7 and 8 in there
the way that works is that's going to
allow you to roll back to previous
versions of your api proxy
and in some cases you might make changes
in there that i would consider a
revision but not a version
so i would consider a version something
that breaks the contract with the client
and if you change around the payload
that's sent back in such a way that it
would break the client then that needs
to be a new version with a new url
if you're just adding caching or fixing
the way that your proxy works but that
doesn't
necessarily change the data that goes
back and forth that's just a revision
so those two things together can make up
revisioning and versioning
will apigee export a proxy to open api
format as well as import it that way
you can definitely import one that way
so you can there's a whole spec editor
inside of apigee and you can edit your
specs in there
and you can publish them out to the
portal that way we do have some tools
out on github that'll introspect an
existing api proxy and make an attempt
to
generate an open api spec if you work
with
a whistle and you're doing a soap
service that part of the soap wizard
there will automatically generate one
for you
what about role-based access control how
do we keep people from seeing stuff they
shouldn't see
a good question as i went through this
i'm the administrator yeah i can see all
kinds of stuff in there and i can push
to production
a typical way of doing this is there's a
role-based access system
in there and we would use that to
control what people have access to so i
might have access to
a staging place or a qa environment but
i don't have access
to production and we might use service
apis in order to push things into
production so we might use the the ui
for some of our development work
but then we're going to check the source
code into git we're going to pull down
from there maybe run some tests on it
and then we'll have that automatically
pushed into production
is it possible to combine the results
from more than one backend build an
aggregate or a composite
it is so go out on youtube and search
for
apogee up close and you'll find i did a
whole webcast on the topic so
just in summary what you do is you can
call out to two or three backend
services
and then typically you would use one of
the programming languages java
javascript or python
and build a composite result in there to
send back but yeah we've got a whole
webcast on that
is apigee only for people that have
external api programs do people use it
for internal api programs
they do so yeah oddly enough most people
are using it for internal api programs
we have a small subset of people who
have
external facing apis and it's fantastic
for that
but the same kind of benefits you might
get when you're running an external api
program those could be used
inside your company for people that are
external to your group
so same concept but used internally
does apogee support open api spec
version 3
yes it does so yeah you can try that out
in the spec editor
can apigee return a different response
based on an accept header for example
json or xml
yes that's something we see pretty
commonly so let's say you have an
existing
soap service and you want to have that
return either xml
or json depending on how somebody calls
it so you can put a condition in there
and that condition would be used to
determine whether it runs the xml to
json policy
and that would return it it would behave
differently depending on how you call
which header you send in
so nice way and very easy to build an
intelligent api like that that's going
to respond with what people need
can you use apogee to control access to
a cloud function
you certainly can so it's a common use
case for that you might have a service
account enabled for
your cloud function and then you'd put
apigee in front of it only apigee would
be able to access that with credentials
and then you might manage the security
to the outside world with oauth tokens
that are managed by apigee
can you export analytics data using an
api yes
there's a whole api in there for getting
an analytics data check the apigee
documentation and within there you'll
see that there's an api
you can specify a time range and you can
pull down analytics data
programmatically let's say the back end
changes can you pre-populate or
invalidate that cache that you're using
in there
so yes you can there's policies to
adjust the cache programmatically you
could also
run that through the ui there's a tool
in there to flush the cache
and you can do it through a service api
where you call the cache directly
and you could pre-populate it or you
could flush it if the back end is
changed
can you route traffic to different
backend servers based on something you
know about the identity of the calling
application so for example partner a and
partner b
both call the same url but they should
be routed to different backend servers
sure so what is typically done in there
is when you generate an api
key or an oauth token you can apply
custom metadata to that so you would put
in there something that lets you know
which partner this is or
or gives an idea of some sort of
identity that that you can use
that becomes a variable when their call
comes in so as soon as it processes the
oauth token or the api key
that data is loaded as a variable and
you have a condition in there and you
can supply multiple backend targets
inside of apigee
and you can set up a route role so
that's all built in to do that you would
look at that attribute and then route to
a or b
based on that is it possible to have
different quotas for the same api so for
example
person a and person b both call the same
url but are limited in different ways
it is so oftentimes we'd put a quota on
the api product
and then when you go to generate a key
you would either choose one product or
the other depending on what you want
that quota to be
so when those two people call that api
using
different api keys they'd be rate
limited differently
what are the key features of an api
gateway so i made a point in here of
distinguishing between a gateway and an
api management platform
a gateway tends to be more security
focused so this is the gateway that
we're going to use to let people in
and it's going to check oauth tokens and
send them to send them along if they
have one and block them if they don't
so a gateway tends to be more around
that more networking based
and then an api management platform is
considering all these people
so it expands on the gateway with the
ability to manage developers to manage
keys to have analytics and things like
that so that's a
a much bigger solution than a simple
gateway sometimes the gateway is
appropriate for what you're doing and
sometimes you need a full api management
solution
so question in here about what is the
use of custom attributes and products
can you share an example where that's
useful
so yeah that goes back to the other
question when i created an api
product i might put a key on there and
that's going to be propagated to all the
apps that are generated
so basically that attribute will go on
to
any keys that are generated for apps and
then it is it comes through as a
variable
and you might use that for conditional
expressions so you might have a policy
that
either executes or doesn't based on that
or you may have routing rules based on
that to send them to different places
or the quota might be enforced based on
that i think that's about all we've got
for time today so i'm going gonna go
ahead and wrap it up thank you so much
for attending today we appreciate it
we'll see in the next webcast